poursuit tout de suite avec Jean-Hugues
Lafleur qui est le vice-président
exécutif chef de la direction financière
d'Hydro-Québec puis la fleur bonsoir
bonsoir mais poursuivons tout de suite
sur Churchill phrase est-ce que
Churchill force pour vous chef de la
direction financière qui rapporte quand
même beaucoup d'argent et névralgique
pour l'avenir d'Hydro-Québec je vous
dirais névralgie c'est un très grand mot
parce qu'on est quand même d'autres
options qu'on pourrait toujours aller
mettre l'avant ça faisait plus de
production éventuellement puis d'où là
dans le fond le but de cette commencer
la négociation dès maintenant c'est dans
18 ans bien échéant ce contrat on a
besoin quand même d'avoir une réponse au
cours des prochaines années là pour
savoir ce qu'ils sont intéressés de
négocier avec nous puis est-ce qu'on
peut on peut s'entendre sur un
renouvellement de contrat et c'est quand
même 15 % de l'approvisionnement
d'Hydro-Québec tout à fait 15% en termes
de puissance 5000 MW de puissance sur
vous avez vu par exemple
lorsqu'il y a une très grande foi de fin
janvier on est monté à 42000 de demande
d'électricité ne s'aimaient du côté de
ce qui est clair pour vous comme chef de
la direction financière qui est
éventuellement ce contrat sera moins
payant pour le Québec parce que
Terre-Neuve veut pas accepter ce qu'ils
ont accepté en 1969 là oh tout à fait il
faut être plus cher que ce sera jamais
point de sous là ça va être beaucoup
plus cher que ça ça y a pas de doute ça
va être un prix juste de marcher puis
certainement Terre-Neuve ont tout
intérêt à
Signal avec Hydro-Québec signer une
entente avec Hydro-Québec puisque je
dirais c'est que s'il y a pas d'entente
les deux on va être perdants là c'est
une certitude dans ça les deux parties
vont être perdantes s'il y a pas
d'entente les marchés d'exportation
quand on regarde vos résultats
financiers aujourd'hui ont été
particulièrement lucratif au cours de la
dernière année est-ce que dans votre
esprit c'est une année exceptionnelle on
n'aura pas des prix comme ça dans
l'avenir
tout à fait c'est exceptionnel dans le
sens que ça a été une conjoncture de
donc déjà en janvier 2022 avec le très
grand froid qui a eu ça fait monter tous
les prix sur dans le nord-est américain
en fait donc déjà au captais on allait
capturer les prix qui était intéressant
sur les marchés ensuite arrive la guerre
en Ukraine ce qui fait en sorte que là
tous les prix en fait en Europe partout
gaz naturel du côté nord-américain et
prix d'électricité se sont mis à monter
c'est de ça qu'on a bénéficié c'est très
à dire mais ça a eu un impact favorable
sur les résultats d'Hydro-Québec et ce
qui est donc nécessairement plus payant
de signer des accords long terme en
termes d'approvisionnement extérieur
comme avec le Massachusetts c'est avec
New York est-ce qu'on s'assure d'avoir
des meilleurs prix dans l'avenir en
faisant ça mais c'est une bonne question
parce que dans le fond l'an dernier
quand on a regardé évidemment une
évolution des prix puisque c'est les
prix spots c'est 35 karawatters c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de volume à vendre
puis donc on est pleinement exposé ça va
être une très bonne année 8.2 sous mais
c'est exceptionnel dans le sens que
c'était la conjoie c'était la
conjoncture qui qui faisait ça cette
année dès le début continue qu'on a très
peu d'hiver froid les pieds il y a une
abondance de gaz naturel qui est venu
donc ce qui fait en sorte que les prix
se sont se sont affaissés sont revenus
plus à un niveau normal donc là on
regarde les deux contrats qu'on a signé
avec le même pardon avec les
massacchusetts
les deux contrats maintenant sont très
intéressants mais pensez qu'on les
regardait ils sont peut-être moins
intéressants mais à long terme donc
conseil un contrat ce qu'on échange tout
simplement du variable qu'on du fixe
puis on veut recevoir fixe notre le prix
d'électricité c'est des bons contrôles
c'est vraiment la loi sur Hydro-Québec
vous oblige à conserver une partie des
bénéfices pour investir dans les
infrastructures dans les barrages dans
les lignes de transmission et la
vérificatrice générale disait récemment
que le réseau est moins fiable qu'il
l'était la transition énergétique va
demander beaucoup investissement
supplémentaire est-ce que ça fait aussi
sa pression sur vos finances
mais ça fait pression sur nos finances
oui mais c'est pas dans l'enjeu de
maintenant c'est pour justement pouvoir
être sûr certains que notre niveau de
fiabilité est élevé puis de pouvoir
satisfaire notre clientèle donc c'est
même pas c'est même pas une question de
rentabilité de dire on le fait on le
fait on le fait tout simplement c'est
que la conjoncture qui a eu au cours des
dernières années avec beaucoup beaucoup
de mises en chantier là je les mises
enchanté au Québec ont été importantes
puis les gens qui font la maintenance et
les mêmes gens qui sont vont faire le
raccordement également ceux si on
regarde juste au niveau par exemple de
la végétation
c'est pour vraiment élaguer les les
arbres on est passé de 60 millions en
2018 à plus de 100 millions aujourd'hui
en termes de de coûts que ça nous coûte
donc on fait affaire avec les
entrepreneurs on serait prête à aller à
120 millions s'il y avait plus
d'entrepreneurs qui étaient disponibles
mais là la pénurie de main d'oeuvre nous
frappe de ce côté-là ce qui fait en
sorte qu'on est même pas capable
d'atteindre nos niveaux on reporte de
ces travaux là je comprends bien tout à
fait
par-dessus deux pannes majeures qui sont
arrivés qui ont concentré nos efforts
pendant des pendant un mois pratiquement
là ce qui fait en sorte que nos nos gens
de métiers ont pas pu à ce moment-là
faire la maintenance mais c'est c'est
quelque chose qu'on adresse absolument
et là on est des événements météo qui
sont de plus en plus importants des
réchauds de mai
20223 décembre si je me trompe pas 24
décembre la grosse tempête avant Noël
les vents violents ça coûte de plus en
plus cher ça aussi ça va faire plus de
pression sur les finances d'Hydro-Québec
dans l'avenir mais habituellement parce
que si on regarde par exemple en 2022 ça
a été un coup de au-delà de 100 millions
de coûts les deux pannes ont coûté plus
de 100 millions sur le bénéfice net
est-ce que de la façon qu'on va qu'on va
opérer au cours des prochaines années
mais on regarde les changements
climatiques on regarde quand on a qu'on
fait des réflexions d'équipements
d'actifs qui ont fait des conférences
des nouveaux actifs puis on les planifie
on se dit ben c'est quoi la meilleure
façon c'est pour qu'il soit quand même
qui qui est dans un contexte d'évolution
des changements climatiques qui vont
nous affecter donc pour éviter justement
ce genre de panne-là puis OK parfait on
va suivre de près bien sûr tous les
autres dossiers l'histoire des barrages
notamment chez la fleur merci merci
d'avoir été avec merci beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]